عوده السوق الصينيه لملعب الرحلات
السياحيه البحريه قد يحدث في اواخر 20 23
او اول العام المقبل اعلان البلادي عدد
فتح حدودها واستئناف حركه السياحه
الخارجيه ثلاثه اعوام اغلقت فيها الصين
حدودها في عقاب تفشي كورونا وكلفت الشركات
البحريه خسائر هائله قبل الوباء كانت
السوق الصينيه تمثل ثاني اكبر سوق سياحي
لرحلات كروز او سفن سياحيه ضخمه بعد
الولايات المتحده واكبر عشره اضعاف من
مثيليها في اليابان وبالمناسبه الصيني
انتهت تقريبا من بناء اول سفينه سياحيه
ضخمه محليه الصبح والتي قد تدخل مراحل
التجارب في يوليو المقبل هذا هو على كل
حال محور نقاشنا اليوم مع ضيفتنا سمر
المشطه في الجانب الاقتصادي ولكن نذهب
اليك يا علاء لنتعرف على ارباح سوق رحلات
البحريه العالمي في فقره في الارقام
في 2019 ربحت صناعه الرحلات البحريه
العالميه نحو 30 مليون مسافر وساهمت باكثر
من 154 مليار دولار في الاقتصاد العالمي
واليكم مزيدا من الارقام
214 دولارا هو متوسط تكلفه الرحله البحريه
لكل مسافر في اليوم الواحد سبعه عشره
سفينه فاخره جديده تم اطلاقها في عام 2022
وهو اقل من 2021 الذي شهد اطلاق 24 سفينه
اما العدد الاجمالي فيبلغ
322 سفينه مليار دولار هي تكلفه اكبر
سفينه في العالم التي تسمى ايقونه البحار
التي من المفترض ان يكتمل بناؤها في اواخر
العام الجاري لتكون الاغلى في التاريخ
وتضم حديقه مائيه وقاعه حفلات معنا وفير
واربعين مطعما واخيرا خمسه مليار دولار هو
حجم ايرادات الرحلات البحريه المتوقع
بحلول عام 2006
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا سمر المشطه الصحفيه في قسم
الاقتصاد اهلا بك سمر صباح الخير
صباح الخير طيب المره الماضيه تحدثنا عن
منافسه الصينيه في الاجواء بتصنيعها
الطائرات اليوم بدنا نتحدث عن منافسه في
المحيطات تفاصيل اكثر معك صحيح سهام اليوم
يعني
الدول الاوروبيه وخصوصا الشركات الاولمبيه
اللي هي محتكره تقريبا 90% من صناعه السفن
اليوم تحذر من وتسميه دخول ادخال القرش
الصيني الى المحيطات والبحار الاوروبيه
وكلهم خايفين من مساله سيطره الصين على
هذا القطاع خصوصا بعد اللي صار خلال العشر
سنوات الماضيه حيث سيطرت الصين على صناعه
القوارب الاصغر قوارب
الشحن فهمنا ثلاث شركات
وحده فرنسيه وواحده ايطاليه ووحده المانيه
مسيطره على هذه الصناعه اللي صاروا انه
طبعا خلال الصين تعاونت مع شركه ايطاليه
تعلمت منها كيف صناعه واحده من الاكبر
الشركات اسمها
تعاونت معاها الصين دفعت لها 250 مليون
يورو وتعاونت مع شركه كرنفال تبع الكروز
تعلمت منهم كيف يقومون ببناء هذه السفن
الكبيره وبلشت ببنائها مثل ما قلتو
بالمقدمه ستسلم اول قارب كبير ساعه 6700
راكب الى كرنفال كروز معروفه هذه الشركه
بالكروز تسلمها بنوفمبر
وتعاقدت معهم على وحده ثانيه سفينه كبيره
ثانيه في 20 25 وهذا ما يثير حفيظه
الشركات الاوروبيه يعني واضح يا سمر انه
الصين كل ما تدخل منافس قوي جدا وهذا
يندرج اكيد كمان ضمن الحرب التجاريه
التنافسيه بين دول الكبرى والصين صارت
تتصدر صحيح اكدت تقطيع خصوصا عندهم ايدي
عامله رخيصه يعني واسعار افضل هذه المشكله
تقدر تنافس بالاسعار طيب لما بنحكي انه
دخل القرش الصيني على المحيطات لكي يبتلع
الكروز
اوروبيا وحتى امريكيا كيف ستكون مميزات
السفن السياحيه الصينيه بالنسبه للمميزات
هم مثل ما قلنا نتعلمه من المعرفه كيف
يصنعوها مثل يعني البارحة شفت صور انا
يعني عادي كروز عاديه مثلها مثل الكروز
الايطاليه مثلا مثل الالمانيه مش لا اعتقل
ابدا هلا ما اعرف شلون تكون بالداخل بس
هناك ايضا ترانز مثلا اليوم تتبع هذه
الكروز عندك مثلا اللي هي تكون صديقه
للبيئه تستعمل وقود صديق للبيئه كل شيء
علامات هذه الكروز مثلا معاد تدويره هاي
وحده من الاشياء ايضا هناك اليوم بعض
الشركات اللي هي مش من ناحيه التصنيع هناك
بعض الشركات اليوم تقوم ايضا بترين جديد
هو اطلاق رحلات سنويه تاخذين ثلاث سنين
واحده من الكروز اطلقت ما راح اذكر اسمها
تنطلق من اسطنبول في واحد نوفمبر تشترين
ثلاث سنين ثلاث الف دولار بالسنه عالشخص
وتقدرين تزورين 135 دوله خلال هذه الثلاث
سنين الان من يقوم بشراء هذه التيكتات اول
شيء جماعه
اللي يشتغل عن بعد هناك اقبال كبير على
مثل هذه الكروز وذاك المره تكلمنا عن
التقاعد هناك العديد من المتقاعدين ما
عندهم شيء عنده فلوس يطلع له على كروز ام
ثلاث سنين تدفع 30 الف دولار يعني اذا
تحسبيها اجار واكل وشرب ما هوايه ويطلع
عليها
ثلاث سنين يزور 135 دوله حلو بس يعني هلا
كمان صار شوي
بالعالم خصوصا بعد كورونا صار في
سينوفوبيا صح صح انا واحده
سفن اللي صار انه اللي صار انه هناك بلشت
بالتعافي
بربيع 2021 بعدنا ما وصلنا الى مرحله
التعافي يعني كان فيلم رعب اتذكر لما كانت
شو
باليابان انه تشوفين فيروس يزيدوا ناس
يموتون كانه مع فيلم رعب فماذا
بالبحر فلازال هذه الصوره عالقه في اذهان
الاشخاص بس بدات رحله التعافي بعشرين واحد
وعشرين من المتوقع انه شويه ها نصل الى من
ناحيه العوائد يعني مبيعات هذا القطاع او
مبيعات ممكن في بدايه العامل
في نهايه هذا العام ممكن نقترب من مستويات
ما قبل كورونا وايضا عدد المسافرين من
المتوقع انه 28 مليون مسافر يسافرون هذا
السنه على متن الكروز 20% منهم من
الصينيين مثل ما ذكرنا بالمقدمه ايضا
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر
صحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد شكرا كثير شكرا